this episode brought to you by the black
tux premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
remember the nightmare fuel and son of
the mask I know which one this one
[Music]
imagine that for an hour and a half
don't want to I did and you're gonna
suffer with me
based on the animated character who
became a hit in the 40s the Woody
Woodpecker movie targets this American
icon on its most American audience
Brazil no joke
Brazil is where this film premiered and
they didn't even bother with a big
screen release in America it just went
straight to DVD I don't know what kind
of sign that is but judging by the ton
of people that want me to review this
I'm assuming bad I have no real life or
dislike for winning woodpecker he seemed
perfectly serviceable for what his
character was supposed to be but from
what I'm hearing in this film there's a
definite pecker that needs to be chopped
in it let's see what's good enough for
Brazil but apparently not us this is the
Woody Woodpecker movie Universal whoa
maybe Woody's part of the dark universe
that's what Tom Cruise changed into at
the end of the Maumee and by god he's
more scary looking that I could have
imagined we open with woody waking up in
his tree to find poachers illegally
hunting in the forest definitely part of
the dark universe why do it swishing
effects look like firecracker popsicles
[Music]
this film knows how to update woody its
pop-culture references are only twenty
years old as opposed to 79 with a brain
the size of a walnut
that's the people who pre-lit this now
there has to be a way to make this even
more 90s
oh look people in suits connected to oil
instantly bad you killing bastards and
yes that is Lassie from psych who is
apparently being fired because he said
he didn't care for a wildlife in an
interview wildlife don't vote wildlife
don't pay taxes though if there is
humanizes Woody Woodpecker shouldn't
they his plan is to create a country
estate on the border of Canada to flip
it and make a huge profit a country
estate we're gonna flip it take a huge
profit I'm gonna start my own firm I
just know the kids who want to see the
Woody Woodpecker movie are following all
of that meanwhile we see woody relaxing
on the pond belching
and we immediately cut away from it
sorry audience that was an essential
bourbon the film would fall apart
without it but his ex-wife and
presumably ex son drop by to tell him
that her father died and she needs him
to watch her son for a while apparently
enough time to build an entire house
together for a while in this film that's
a lot of time off I'm sorry Linda the
timing is just really bad I would like
to help you but I can't and that's final
now I'm just gonna have you take a wild
guess as to what they cut to next a the
son with a father B who cares what the
rest are because you know it's obviously
a my hands were tied you saw that yeah I
know
that's what that director thought was
funny I know you don't want me here the
only kid you want in your life is your
girlfriend there are so many wrong ways
to interpret that they get to where
they're going to build the house and
decide to make a little food their post
that hashtag epic dad grill fail both of
my followers are gonna love this one of
the Rangers named Sam introduces herself
and lets them know that they've been
having problems with bird poachers not
enough problems in my opinion I hear
you're building a house up here 5,000
square feet every amenity don't you
think it'll kind of overwhelm the
landscape and for some reason it looks
like an ice cube tray turning into the
wolf of wallstreet boat the Sun comes
across woody who immediately has a
hankering for some snacks what are you
trying to tell me I'm just a pawn
character I can't actually think in this
movie they seem to form a friendship
I guess despite the film stopping to
tell us otherwise music oh yeah we're
not friends or anything I'm only doing
this for the free food I'm what you call
a food prostitute
I'm gonna call you like that name
woody funny how I can speak English yet
apparently I never had a name my mother
used to call me Jonathan before she was
eaten by yogi the bear that's right what
he's got a backstory nobody he comes
across the rest of the family and they
do not take to his rascally ways or ass
humor
oh yeah when I said ask humor I
literally meant as humor remember the
but is always a treasure-trove to
what he also keeps them up at night
making pecking sounds in the forest give
me that back right now
you know how many times in your life you
get to say I missed the walrus lassie
brings in the bulldozers to start
building the house but what he tries to
stop them no I do not recall so much
focus on Amos in the original cartoons
but it's been a while maybe I remember
him differently the son goes into a
guitar store and meets a girl who works
there I'm Jill
I'm Tommy are you visiting yeah I'm just
gonna let you take a wild guess as to
what their relationship is going to be a
bank robbers B if I don't say anymore
maybe Whoopie bank robbers I can make
you a really sweet deal on that guitar
if you like she tells him if he joins
her band she'll let him have the guitar
for free because I guess she's the store
owner now and he comes across and
bullies who even buy stock bullies
dangers have a pretty weak reason to
hate him hey you don't get off that easy
hey never mind that look at that kid
he's got eyes what he comes into savings
oh and ends this scene as abruptly as it
starts nobody messes with my BFF and by
that I mean bring her up free food sorry
yeah we didn't have a segue or a plot or
writers but I sound great in Portuguese
oh my god no I don't why did we make
this he tells his dad that what he saved
him but neither him or the girlfriend
want to hear it nah mention that stupid
Bart last I remember that stupid bird
wasn't the one covered in burn coupe
that's his Friday night thing go to your
room and in case you were wondering
nobody in town is happy about its
building house appear granted I've only
talked to three people and two of them
are like this
Cockrum and we didn't give you
permission to use it I still think it's
a sound argument things don't get that
much better at night you better fly out
of here right a pinecone okay you know I
totally forgot why I'm supposed to like
anything anywhere
the next day isn't any better as woody
continues to make their lives a living
hell worry I didn't forget about you -
you're my favorites Dick Tracy have I
laughed so hard at somebody drowning in
wet cement lassie goes to the Ranger to
complain about Woody's antics but she
doesn't believe him red Crone woodpecker
has been extinct for almost a hundred
years any chance for taking any sort of
medication well he's only advertised his
existence as loudly as possible in front
of many witnesses in both the wit and
the town are you sure you're not taking
any medication where's Ranger ever a
local Native Americans believed it was
the incarnation of mark Conda whoa what
his backstory is strangely complicated
god of chaos and mayhem mysterious
trickster who haunted the forest this
was meant to be a kid's film right
[Applause]
[Music]
ah the black tux calm tuxedos delivered
right to your door it's just like
ordering a pizza except a lot bigger and
you have to send your measurements
because it's a tuxedo you know what is
nothing like ordering a pizza but when I
want to look good with no hassle at a
good price I do use the black tux calm I
mean everyone wants to look good for
that special event but they don't want
to fork out a ton of money for it either
well the black tux calm is your answer
with high quality rental suits and
tuxedos delivered to your doorstep it's
such an easy way to rent suits and tuxes
online most suits go for something like
1,200 bucks but at the black tux they
start at $95 they let you create your
own look and choose from a ton of great
stylist their expert customer care has
your back every step of the way and it's
completely done online you can even do a
free home try on so you can see the fit
and feel the quality of your suit months
before your big event and after ordering
your suit they'll have it to you 14 days
before the event even starts and if
anything is less than perfect the black
tux will send you a free replacement
right away when your event is over you
just drop your rental back in the mail
and shipping is free both ways and hey
you want to get 20 bucks off your
purchase just visit the black tux comm
slash nostalgia critic that's right just
go to the black tux consolation
nostalgia Creek and you'll get $20 right
off your purchase visit the black tux
comm premium rental suits and tuxedos
delivered
[Applause]
so we quickly see what woody is an
endangered species because he endangered
every species he comes across okay
Woody's a serial killer he takes join
the slaughtering of others and thinks
nothing of the consequences he even
brings death - humor definitely lasting
weren't there poachers in this movie the
girlfriend finally leaves after somehow
surviving that and the son apologizes
for the situation sorry about Vanessa I
know you like to sometimes things don't
work out the way you planned
you have a hit show for years and
sometimes this is the movie you get
lassie comes across the two poachers and
ask them to remove the woodpecker to
which they accept because they know they
can sell them for tons of cash so the
kids stumble across the place where the
poachers stuffed their animals what oh
my god what's gonna happen to them here
well that was anticlimactic reasonable
you had a chance to kill three of the
main characters and you blow it
Who am I kidding we still have to deal
with this universal monster
[Music]
and I thought the PRTs rap and
descendants was also awful I can't even
make a joke out of that would you smells
peanut butter though as the poachers
have a plan to catch him - I join you is
it just me or is there something kind of
wooden about this chick oh I don't know
so far she's the best actor in the whole
thing the trap doesn't work though as
they try sending heat-seeking
tranquilizers after him
[Music]
it's the poachers in the ass as Woody
decides to fire an electric net on
Lassie
wow that is terrifying the collection of
saw victim pictures you have so less he
tries to be nice by constantly offering
woody snacks if he just leaves him alone
so the moral is bribery fixes everything
I know what you folks are thinking woody
is a big fat sellout long before the
film started yes I let them build their
dream house in peace okay even the bear
in the Big Blue House would say that's
too much blue but whatever the house is
made and there's still a half hour left
what the hell else is there to do I
guess that oh wait
more poop jokes
you know this is the only movie I can
think of that can make Kevin Costner's
urine look delicious the kids plan to
perform at the fair but it looks like
the drummer gets sick I'll let you take
oh wow just play it sure those cans can
get that kind of percussion I especially
love the invisible drummer we can't see
the fair releases a bunch of fireflies
because I don't know whimsical hey
matches this last-minute attempt to
throw some heart into Satan's doorstop
here just because I'm one of the kind
doesn't mean I can't be part of a family
too right
I mean I'm aimed and torture them
through 90% of my screen time that has
to be love bunny accidentally starts a
fire burning the place down and of
course let's it gets pissed off at him
hiring the poachers back can I get an
endless loop of that for my screen saver
but let's he stumbles across something
in the rubble he signs his arsons no he
was just making a family portrait which
of course excuses why would he never
told him that he was the one who burned
the place down I'm fine if it makes the
movie go faster the poachers tried to
auction off woody among four
millionaires because clearly they would
have that contact info as the kids
trying to sneak in and save him but they
get caught and thrown in a cage you can
swim through the gaps in that cage
mousetrap is a better holding device
lassie and the Ranger show up though to
do jack is anyone up worth in this
movie lassie leans his cage over though
and lets woody out allowing him to turn
the poachers into a giant CG ball of
yarn easy with every effect aren't they
they ride away though with woody chasing
him down
I'm gonna add your picture to my
collection they passed the friggin easy
as Canadian border to cross
I guess permanently closed means lightly
locked but what are you nuts the ground
out from under him just take us out of
this movie so we can start proper
careers okay that's the last one I can't
promise that this movie said something
right
this film is I can see why this only got
a DVD release in America and I apologize
to Brazil for having to witness it on
50-foot screens this film is like a
Nickelodeon movie of the month except
somehow it actually makes me pray to see
spongebob it looks as bad as it sounds
it sounds as bad as it looks
it's unfunny it's annoying it's worth
flying as far away from as humanly
possible I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember despite how much I don't want
to
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out I'm just gonna give me a heads
up right now today's charity is very
rough but it doesn't have any graphic
images or pictures or anything like that
please definitely consider giving to
this charity it is the Center for
victims of torture this organization
works towards a future in which torture
ceases to exist and its victims have
hope for a new life
they provide direct care for those who
have gone through such terrible acts
trained partners around the world who
can prevent and treat such acts and
advocate for human rights as well as an
end to torture they are forging new ways
to advance human rights and build a
future free from the horrendous things
done to them each initiative plays a
role in building a larger vision for the
torch of rehabilitation movement they
provide a bridge between torture victims
the local community and society as a
whole working to restore the dignity of
the human spirit one survivor at a time
if you look at their site in their
YouTube channel you can see the ways
they helped people overcome what no
person should ever have to go through I
know it's rough to think about that
these are people that can use any ounce
of love that you have and even the
tiniest donation can go a long way
please click on the link and give to
those who have gone from more than we
can imagine and deserve all the healing
[Music]
you